so this you have to see um in advance of
the big christmas holiday this weekend
the former president donald trump sat
down with former arkansas republican
governor mike huckabee
also the dad of trump's own former press
secretary sarah huckabee sanders who
herself is now running as a republican
for governor of arkansas i don't think
i've ever seen an interview like this
and a huge part of the interview is
about a fake issue then that issue is
the so-called war on christmas there's
music playing in the background
mike huckabee is really focused in on
christmas and sort of makes trump out to
be like a hero i guess for saving
christmas for bringing back christmas
see if you can i challenge you see if
you can determine the number of lies
told here let's just jump right into the
first clip
[Applause]
america had gone to a long period where
people quit saying merry christmas
all happy holidays
you deliberately changed that
and openly said merry christmas we're
going to say it again
part of my campaign mike you know the
country had
started with this woke i guess a little
bit before that yeah
and it was embarrassing for
stores to say merry christmas you'd see
these big chains they want your money
but they don't want to say merry
christmas and they'd use reds and then
use whites and snow but they wouldn't
say christmas and when i started
campaigning this was in 2015
when i started campaigning i said you're
going to say merry christmas again and
now people are saying it
of course they're not saying a lot of
other things like george washington
abraham lincoln thomas jefferson you
know those names are being obliterated
because of craziness
so
there was a long period where no one
said merry christmas that's not true
trump said that part of his campaign was
saying merry christmas now that may be
true
but how pathetic is that if it's true
trump's saying it like it's something to
be proud of but it's not it's a joke if
you ran on we're going to say merry
christmas again which by the way we
nobody ever stopped saying merry
christmas it was never embarrassing for
stores to say merry christmas there were
some stores who chose
the more inclusive happy holidays but
like who really cares
and then trump says they also aren't
saying things like george washington
abraham lincoln and thomas jefferson who
isn't saying those names and also what
do those names have to do
with this time of the year like i said
we're reaching this is sort of like
uncharted territory in lies about what
is happening in society and culture
people aren't saying these names and
huckabee just nods along like this makes
sense let's continue into the next clip
but they are saying merry christmas
again we got that that was a big part of
what i was doing and so i would say it
all the time during that period
that we want them to say
merry christmas don't shop at stores
that don't say merry christmas and i'll
tell you we brought it back very quickly
you really did and i think a lot of
people appreciated that it was a part of
the american culture it was a part of
who we are it wasn't uh to exclude
anybody it was just simply a celebration
of what america does at christmas and
america and the world but america loves
christmas yeah and whether you're muslim
whether you're christian whether you're
jewish everyone loves christmas and they
say merry christmas until these crazy
people came along and they wanted to
stop it along with everything else
so i was very proud of that actually
remember i used to say we will say merry
christmas again in front of these
massive crowds of people so trump says
it like it's an administrative
accomplishment we brought back
saying merry christmas christmas and he
says even muslims i don't know why you
pronounce it that way muslims like
christmas as well which is really
something else i still don't know who
cares about this and every time i say
this was not ever a real issue
a couple people will email me and
they'll say david no there was a
cultural backlash at one point where
the woksters were saying you shouldn't
say merry christmas or whatever almost
no one ever cared about this i'm jewish
i recognize most people are christian by
culturally ethnically i'm saying
when someone says merry christmas to me
and it has happened a lot in the last 10
days
i don't get offended
i just don't say it myself i'll either
say thank you and walk away
uh if someone says happy holidays i'll
say likewise happy holidays have a good
new year and sometimes if someone says
merry christmas to me i'll say oh happy
hanukkah like if they're wishing me
something about what they celebrate i'll
wish them happiness for what i celebrate
like it's no big deal people will laugh
it's just it just doesn't matter and
trump is calling this one of his major
accomplishments if you can imagine that
now it is true
he doesn't really have any other
accomplishments to speak of so maybe the
fact that
he says merry christmas is like all he
has to cling to or something like that
there's one more clip in this one
huckabee thanks trump
for not just saying merry christmas but
for giving people good christmases and
this is like
i mean
you know this is like north korean
propaganda
uh huckabee really should be blushing
behind that white beard that he is now
sporting take a look at this mr
president i want to say because of you a
lot of americans have had some great
christmases
you helped rebuild the economy pride in
our country
made us a strong military once again
stood up to china when i think of all
the ways that you led this country
energy independent for the first time in
75 years no longer
i think a lot of people are
right now saying i wish donald trump was
president right now this year for
christmas what a great christmas present
that would be well it's been very sad
when you look we were energy independent
and now they're going to opec again and
and they're begging for oil
and the gasoline price was 1.87 and now
it's in california 7.50 cents a gallon
and it's going to follow that and i said
that during the debates i said when you
watch what they do to energy when you
watch what they do with inflation
inflation is a killer
and so many other things it's it's very
sad
to see what's happening but
our country will survive it
and i really believe we're going to be
greater than ever before a beautiful
christmas message about begging opec for
oil
still trump talking about 750 gas in
california which by the way i was in
california last week i looked everywhere
for the seven dollar
77 cent gas trump talked about now i'm
not saying it never existed maybe there
was some place in california where super
premium was 7.77 i couldn't find it most
expensive i saw was 6.49 let by the way
i didn't put that in my rental car i'm
putting the cheap stuff in the rental
car i can tell you that for sure okay so
a complete and total
propaganda piece there on newsmax and
everybody involved should be completely
embarrassed by it
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription
go to blinkist.com pacman the link is
down below